more on patrick mahomes though and this
is the time of the year where
football players and fans allow
themselves to become so confident that
they cross over into delusion here's
patrick holmes talking about his
aspirations now that we have a 17-game
season and now that he's racking up all
sorts of individual numbers he's got
a team number in mind here he is
the only record in my eyes that i'm
breaking which would be it'd be new this
year going 20 and zero okay
it's not it's not a really a record be
broken i guess you'd say but i think 19
and zero is the record right now so
being able to go 20 and zero be the
first one to do that that'd be awesome
you know i think that umbrella that they
have in the shot is awesome but it's not
functional it's not casting any shade on
patrick no it's doing nothing it's like
it's just there for looks i guess right
uh but but regardless 20 and oh yeah
nobody ever did 19-0 the patriots got as
close as anyone that's a long road to go
17-0
or now yes now you got to go 17 no now
you got to match with the dolphins did
just in the regular season right right
then you got to go in three playoff
games good luck with all that yeah well
it's going to be on you know guys like
patrick mahomes and brady and other
quarterbacks that are great or of that
status yeah it's gonna be on their radar
i mean yeah it's a nice thing to shoot
for is it like something you're like
really realistic about did he write it
like you know on his bathroom mirror to
be like we're going 20 no not at all but
it's just a cool thing to talk about
either way and the chiefs in my homes
aren't afraid to to speak about those
things they're not and at least you know
give it a shot that's for sure
the broader point is he doesn't care
about his own numbers yes right it's
fine right
all that matters is winning a
championship let's not get caught up in
going undefeated just get to super bowl
number two
that's more important because two leads
to three you go 20-0 you still only get
one ring they don't give you a second
ring for going 20-0 and and you know
this reminds me of what tom brady said
during the draft yeah the draft-a-thon
where he made the comment that he would
trade a couple of super bowl rings for a
perfect season that's got to be one of
the things that he still got on his
docket of possibilities they came so
close to it now 14 years ago here's the
first super bowl team to return all the
starters on both sides of the ball since
the steelers of the 70s man yeah and
brady's got to be thinking about that
he's got to be you know that's the way
you stay focused and motivated week in
and week out you avoid having a stumble
every week and look how good the chiefs
were last year they had one stumble
against the raiders yeah and then they
had the game late in the year that they
rested the starters for they have been
other than the you know that buccaneers
game we have a bad memory of the chiefs
from that the chiefs have been
freaking awesome freaking out last
couple of years no doubt about it answer
the bell almost every week
i mean
really it they're unbelievable you're
right there's there's nothing to say
negative about the the chiefs i mean
it's it's been one of the best teams in
football they always compete you know
and of course even when they're having a
down day 15 gives them a chance to still
win a game or stay close or whatever it
may be yeah they're special i don't know
can they make that kind of run this type
you know this year for a fourth year in
a row that's where i've gotten to you
and we've had this conversation to where
i think this is a year they they lose a
few more games and we've seen them lose
the past two years still in the playoffs
but you know that catches up to them all
the long games in the long years and
just being beat up and constantly having
the bullseye on your back and all that
but i will say this mike just going back
to the 20-0 thing to me that's something
that
you know i think a lot of players and
quarterbacks
it it has real i don't know what i want
to say it's just a it'd be a great honor
to be able to go wait we were 20-0 we
were undefeated we won the super bowl as
a quarterback or as a player when you
have that you can always be like we're
the best team ever or i was the
quarterback of the best team ever and i
think that's why you hear sometimes
quarterbacks wax poetically about it or
think about it
and whether it's the buccaneers or the
chiefs when you have that standard of
excellence and high achievement in the
regular season if you are focused on
going 20-0 it will carry you through
those moments where you would otherwise
step in a pothole and pick up a loss
once you get your first loss using that
as the motivation in the games that
aren't all that significant that goes
out the window but uh hey these guys are
perfectionists these guys are crazy in a
in a good way they want to win they want
to win every week and and you know
chiefs fans
should be paying close attention to all
these
situations involving quarterbacks and
front offices or coaching staffs and
dysfunction and they should be very glad
what when
uh oh peter was on the show friday we we
had a draft of the next wave of
quarterbacks who may make power plays
mahomes is nowhere even close to the
board no my home's it's amazing it just
isn't wired that way you never have to
worry about it watch as i say this it's
going to be three years away he's
jostling for a new team but i he he
won't that that's they have ultimate
incredible quarterback plus ultimate
incredible
teammate player
part of the organization who wants to be
there and isn't going to make a power
play isn't going to try to get out of
town and chiefs fans have to feel good
about that because now every team that
has a great quarterback has to worry
when does this go haywire and we go
through this extended stretch of the
quarterback trying to get out of town
yeah no it's it's amazing you know
that's it's he's going to scare people
that way because he is talented you're
right and he's shown that he's you know
not selfish so
he's willing to take a little less and
go
okay you know i only have 200 million in
the bank when i cur when my career ends
instead of 220 and that's okay i mean
we've had that conversation i would be
one of those guys that's a lot of money
i know but when you have that much money
already it's not as much so and hey the
other thing too mike i i've thought
about this a few times recently
like we've talked about the bucks all 22
starters back and everything like that
i think one of the coolest things of
this off season is this team we're
talking about that's kind of dominated
the nfl for three years in a row
got like
significantly better two this offseason
let's not forget what they did on the
offensive line with toonie and orlando
brown jr and kyle long and then to also
let's not forget get geron reed a
defensive tackle from the seattle
seahawks he's a pro bowl defensive
tackle you know they got a guy like
deandre baker who's a first round pick
and had his off-field issues who might
resurface or show up here trade for mike
hughes from the for the from your
minnesota vikings like they're a team
that is always aggressive and doesn't
stand put and that's where i respect
them too to where they had a sneaky
really awesome offseason themselves
well and they needed to make some
changes they saw what happened in super
bowl 55 and they decided we've got to do
some work or we're going to lose our
grip on the division on the conference
they've got two straight super bowl
appearances could have been three was
close to three it was a coin toss away
from them having a shot at three so
uh hey look the chiefs are here to stay
they're gonna be in the conversation
every year and
as to keeping mahomes happy yeah the
challenge is going to be to monitor the
market at quarterback monitor the salary
cap and be willing at the right time to
go in and adjust his contract to make it
more fair to him
so you avoid a situation where he feels
like he's not being treated fairly you
know i think that's going to be the test
for brett veach andy reid and clark hunt
in a couple of years will they
affirmatively approach patrick holmes
and say we're going to take care of you
because we see what's going on elsewhere
we see by virtue of other contracts that
we could say oh those are stupid oh they
don't know what they're doing oh they're
paying too much at a certain point the
contracts add up to the point where it's
unavoidable you either care about the
person you have yeah or you don't they
will the one way you show you care about
them is you start paying them like the
others are getting paid i think they
will uh listen i just you know as far as
people go i don't know veach read it
seems as good as it gets that way it
really does and i don't think they're
the type of people that are going to
look there and go
you know we're screwing them over he's
making 20 less million than everybody
else in football he's the best player i
don't they'll find a way whether it's
through more bonuses extending whatever
i i really do i just i i think they got
something special there with just the
people and that's why i don't think like
you know they're not like you said
they're not going anywhere because i
don't think like they don't put pressure
on them they have fun there they're just
it seems like a different atmosphere
than a normal team that's you know three
years in a row super bowl afc
championship all those type of things
that's why last year i thought they
would go back to the super bowl i think
they enjoy being the biggest show on in
the nfl and they they like the bright
lights and just playing and let's let it
fly and that's why the pressure doesn't
get to them and they're not going
anywhere mike i agree with you
you know i recently poked around to see
what if any adjustments the chiefs were
making to their offseason program
in response to the this trend that we're
seeing where coaches are doing less less
time less intensity and the chiefs don't
have a very intense off-season program
anyway it's to your point that they're
not as hard driving and hard charging
and over the top and focused during the
off season as maybe some of these other
teams are and uh it's worked so far for
the chiefs whatever they're doing keep
doing it because they have gone from you
know a team that was just kind of
perpetually stuck in mud they'd get
close they'd lose playoff games at home
they'd lost so many playoff games at
home in a row before they finally you
know turned it around and and with
patrick mahomes just keep just whatever
you do
keep him happy
do what it takes to keep him happy give
him personnel input give him money do
whatever you keep that guy happy because
as we see more and more quarterbacks
exercise their power you just don't want
patrick holmes to ever be a guy who
chooses to do that and if they play it
right he won't be
no they won't i mean he's not that kind
of guy and hopefully they're smart
enough to realize to not play that game
with patrick mahomes they are fun to
watch and i think it is because of the
people running that organization you're
right they kind of were
like your vikings relevant every year
but then they got this guy that
quarterback and they went to a whole
another level of like yeah relevant for
the super bowl conversation not relevant
for just making the playoffs or being
that and that's where they have a real
real advantage over your team
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports